you told me the story of the war when  the ground shook in the sky burn  of the ones that survived  who will walk to a different world where  the powerful preyed on me but that's not  the way it has to be when I found you  you're very human brain was miraculously  abducted it's the loneliest feeling not  to know who you are in time you'll  remember  [Music]  Oh  the leaders knew it here it's harsh  world down here did that'll be willing  to do what it takes  [Music]  Michaels  she's the last of a kind  she contains technology that have been  lost for 300 years  let me show you something  [Music]  this body I feel a connection to it I  can't explain you know more about me  than you're saying  Aveda some things have been and left  forgotten and I'll find out for myself  she's threatening the natural order of  things I need you to destroy her a  leader they will come for you I'll have  to face them head-on  tonight is not a game  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  I'm with her  [Music]